understanding workload management in
bigquery is
key to making efficient use of system
resources
and optimizing performance in today's
episode of bigquery spotlight
we're talking about jobs the reservation
model
and best practices for managing and
controlling work in bigquery
so let's get started
[Music]
a job is an action that bigquery runs on
your behalf
it can either be a query extract load or
copy job
when you're performing actions in the
console for example
writing a query against one of your data
sets bigquery will go ahead and create a
job
on your behalf each job has an
associated user identity
that created the job a location or the
region where the job is actually
executed which must be the same location
as the data that you're using in the job
and a status either pending running or
done
because jobs have the potential to take
a long time to complete
bigquery executes them asynchronously
meaning each job is run independently
and you can execute multiple jobs
at a time without needing to finish the
current job to move on to the next one
since jobs are all doing some
computational work
each job will need to use some compute
resources
in bigquery a unit of compute is called
a slot
which is essentially a worker a slot
is made up of cpu ram and network
bigquery automatically calculates how
many slots are required by each job
depending on the size of the data and
the complexity of the logic
when bigquery executes a query it uses
the query plan
to execute different aspects at
different stages
each stage of the query may actually use
a different number of slots
if there isn't a slot available bigquery
may take
longer to finish the query as it waits
for one to free up
before we talk about how different jobs
consume slots
let's talk about how you can get access
to slots
as a reminder bigquery offers two
different pricing models
first there's on-demand where you pay
for the amount of bytes scanned in query
jobs
in this model you get 2 000 slots in
each bigquery project
alternatively there's flat rate pricing
where you purchase
a number of dedicated slots for your
workloads
flat rate customers purchase slots in
the form of commitments
that are either annual monthly or flex
which can be canceled after just 60
seconds
with the flat rate model you can decide
the amount of slots you need available
for your team's bigquery usage
plus you have predictable pricing
once you have purchased a commitment you
can split that commitment into
any number of reservations a reservation
is essentially a bucket of slots
that you can allocate to specific jobs
for example you might have a bi
reservation that is used for
all business intelligence queries and an
elt reservation
that is used for all data transformation
queries
once you have a reservation in place you
can create an assignment
which assigns those slots to your whole
organization
a specific folder or even a single
project
each level in the resource hierarchy
inherits the assignment from the level
above
unless you override it now what's really
cool
is that idle slots are available for
other reservations in your organization
to use
so if no one is loading a dashboard the
slots in your bi reservation
can be used for elt jobs
all slots available to these resources
will be distributed fairly among
projects
and then jobs within those projects
meaning if there is one query that is
being run in the project
it will have the ability to use all the
available slots
if there are two queries that are being
run then each will have access to half
of the slots
and so on so it's unlikely that one
resource heavy query
will overpower the system and steal
resources from other running queries
when you create an assignment you
specify the type of job that the
assignment will be used for
for example query assignments are used
for query jobs
pipeline jobs on the other hand are used
for extract
copy and load jobs and a quick side note
on this
by default load copy and export jobs are
free
and use a shared pool of slots but
bigquery makes no guarantees
on available slots which is why you may
want to create a pipeline reservation
when jobs are assigned to a pipeline
assignment they lose access to that free
pool
so make sure that jobs have enough
capacity otherwise
performance could be worse than using
the free pool
finally there are also ml external
assignments
for bigquery machine learning queries
that use external services
now let's consider how these resources
fit within the broader
bigquery resource hierarchy
commitments reservations and assignments
are created within a project
sometimes referred to as the admin
project
many organizations choose to purchase
all commitments
from a single project to make it easier
to monitor
these resources also live within a
specific location
commitments will be billed to the admin
project but
these slots are available to be used by
any jobs within the organization
reservations can be also applied to the
whole
organization or to any other folder or
project
where they can then be used by jobs that
are executed in that same location
this means that you might have queries
that were run in the u.s
northeast 1 region using slots that you
purchased
but other queries in the same project
that were run in the u.s multi-region
might be running on demand now that you
have an
understanding of jobs and the
reservation model let's see it in action
inside the bigquery console i can
purchase slots from the reservation page
here i will go ahead and purchase 1 000
black slots
in the united states multi-region let's
go ahead and confirm that
great now once i have my commitment i'm
able to create a reservation
here i'll create a reservation that
allocates 500 of my slots
to handle queries from my business
intelligence tool
with my reservation in place i can
create an assignment that ties this
reservation
to my project where bi queries are run
now when a query is run in this project
it will use slots
in my reservation
to drill into this further i can use the
job id
to select the execution details from the
information schema
here i can see which reservation it used
and how many slots it used on average
throughout the stages of the query
execution
look out for an upcoming video on
bigquery monitoring
where we'll go into detail on how you
can use the information schema
to understand utilization and make
decisions around reservation sizes
amazing so now you know all about the
bigquery reservation model
today we talked about the standard
bigquery reservation model
but you may also hear the term
reservation when digging into bi engine
bigquery's in-memory execution engine
that allows for
super fast queries a good way to
differentiate between the two
is that bi engine reservation allocates
memory
for intelligent caching while standard
reservations
allocate compute or slots
if you want to learn more about bigquery
check out the rest of our playlists and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
on youtube for other great content look
out for our next episode of bigquery
spotlight
and remember stay curious